[Music]
[Music]
when you need to see the bigger picture
sometimes it's best to return to your
roots Assassin's Creed origins takes us
thinking to heart and steps into the
seamless and dynamic open-world of
ancient Egypt although this move shows
glimmers of a brighter future for the
series it also becomes clear that it's
core gameplay and presentation have some
difficulties keeping up with the
newfound pace and scale learn the lines
between prequel and sequel Assassin's
Creed origins takes us back to the
beginning of the assassin Brotherhood
while also laying the groundwork for a
new present-day storyline set during the
time of the Ptolemaic Kingdom in Egypt
you take on the role of byuk a Magi
ranger who embarks on a quest for
revenge against a mysterious order that
predates the templars he'll sneak loot
and stab key figures in the social and
political worlds of Egypt leading to
unforeseen consequences for the future
of the kingdom right up to the present
day events they told me from my throne
and why should I get above them the
snake has many heads those heads make up
the order in its 30 our main story
you'll travel to a number of areas
across Egypt meeting different allies
and villains with their own agendas
while references to significant
characters and events from other games
are present they take a backseat to the
twin narratives of origins particularly
- that a bike and his companions as they
lay the foundations of their Creed in
Egypt moving steadily away from the
somewhat identical formula of past
Assassin's Creed games where you
gradually move out to different hub
areas and tackled largely isolated
missions origins gives you a greater
level of freedom and agency in a more
seamless world where you take part in
activities at your leisure with each
region possessing several points of
interest veering off the paths to find
sites unseen can yield valuable loot
history about the world and other
secrets that tie into something greater
while some locations share a few too
many similarities in style and general
landscape and others are frustratingly
sparse with content and activity the
world is beautifully realized with great
attention to detail
which houses a number of AI systems that
play off one another from the flocks of
birds that rise in unison while running
through marshlands to the crocodiles
that pluck sailors off their boats
trekking through the many rivers the
aesthetic and wool design of Assassin's
Creed origins is one of the series's
finest achievements it thankfully makes
good on the potential of its setting
showing off the clash of ideologies and
cultures during Ptolemaic Egypt in
giving it life in a number of surprising
ways illustrating the conflict between
greco-roman and Egyptian influences the
core narrative and sight stories are
engaging and feel meaningful even
tackling issues of racism colonialism
and the systemic misogyny at the times
this is especially relevant to biock who
is himself an outsider in many of the
locations he travels to and as a result
witnesses some of the abuse firsthand
origins definitely handles its a world
tone by balancing moments of heartbreak
and earnestness such as side stories
dealing with greedy landowners poisoning
lower-class citizens with moments of
levity like when bike entertains
children across the many cities in Egypt
unfortunately several technical hiccups
and bugs crop up which can really
disrupt the flow of the experience
during our playthrough of the Xbox one X
and ps4 versions instances of texture
pop-in
noticeable framerate dips during
cutscenes and gameplay and odd graphical
issues impact moments and events that
should be meaningful these issues
unfortunately persist throughout
slightly dragging down the otherwise
incredible setting
[Music]
origins also make some overhauls of the
style and tone of combat trading steel
with enemies now feels more active and
involved thanks to its dynamic strikes
and real-time blocking and parrying
while certain traces of the series is
group-oriented action remain combat
focuses more on the smaller skirmishes
where you pick your moments and strike
at the right time
moreover range combat has also been
improved adding greater maneuverability
and accuracy including a useful slow-mo
aim while leaping through the air though
this new approach to combat it initially
feels like an improvement all around
making battles more engaging and
involved some of these changes give rise
to problems that can make them a drag
while combat is solid when fighting a
limited number of enemies things quickly
turn south when more enemies are added
into the mix turning bigger battles into
clunky affairs this is especially
problematic with a walk on camera that
follows the action for two closely
turning battles that could be tactical
and fierce into disorienting and clumsy
encounters in some cases it felt better
fighting without lock-on enabled to
better keep track of what's going on
this clumsiness is even present in the
stealth system which is more awkward
than it was in past games somehow slower
and deliberate movement can feel
unreliable due to controls that feel
less accurate and unresponsive byuk can
sometimes hitch onto ledges and other
objects when he gets close enough
frequently resulting in accidental
exposure to enemies sneaking feels
undermined by these problems or there
comes from enemies seeing through
objects or instances where a our
partners routinely walk into danger
stealth is often more of a hassle than
it's worth making in one of the weaker
aspects of origins
Assassin's Creed origins attempts to
blend the established stealth action
elements with the mechanics of an action
RPG but these two halves don't always
coalesce by including staff building in
a Luke run it creates needless level
gating for areas of the map this results
in time spent grinding to acquire vital
skills and resources and in the broader
sense can feel like artificial padding
this in turn conflicts with the feeling
of being a skillful assassin who uses
resources to maneuver through enemy
hideouts on his wits and then finding
out your assassination won't work due to
an underpowered hidden blade assassin's
creed origins reaches great heights in
his new setting it routinely runs into
issues that bogged down the overall game
technical issues make for an uneven
experience and its new gameplay pillars
wobble under the weight of its systems
but despite this the world of origins
remains fresh and exciting to explore
which is a testament to the remarkable
setting and compelling story Assassin's
Creed is a series has undergone many
changes in its long and storied history
and origins feels like the first step in
the start of something new it has its
fair share of problems but the vision
for its future is one worth pursuing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]